[MUSIC PLAYING]
SILVANO LUCIANI:
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google+ Developers
Live, Google+
Sign-In with iOS.
I'm Silvano Luciani.
I'm a developer programs
engineer for the Google+
platform, and not only my hair
is upside down, my shirt is
upside down, too.
XIANGTIAN DAI: And I'm
Xiangtian Dai.
And I'm a software engineer for
the Google+ iOS platform.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So the
topic today is iOS.
And as you might know,
at Google we
produce also iOS apps.
Google Maps is a
clear example.
Our own Google+ iOS apps is a
very cool and compelling app.
Not only we produce amazing
apps, we also want you to
produce a compelling app.
So we want to give you the tools
to be able to produce an
engaging experience
for your users.
And that's why we have
the Google+ SDK.
So what are we going to
show today, Xiangtian?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Today we're
going to show first the
Google+ Quickstart sample app
inside of Google+ SDK.
We'll walk through with it.
And the second, we're going to
create a new iOS project from
scratch that has the Google+
iOS Sign-In button.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Wait.
You're doing an app from
scratch, from empty to
Google+, and then working in
10 minutes, live, now?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
And maybe even less than that.
SILVANO LUCIANI: I really
want to see it.
So let's start.
First, if we want to get started
with iOS, just go to
our developer's documentation
site,
developers.google.com/plus.
On the left, now, at the very
top, you can find the
Quickstart section.
And the Quickstart is our set of
sample application that we
produce for many different
language that will get you
started with the platform
in less than 10 minutes.
So we have Android, C#, Java,
JavaScript, PHP, Python, Ruby.
But today, we are interested
in iOS.
So if we click on iOS, this is
when we can get started with
the set-up process for
the Quickstart.
But before doing this,
Xiangtian, what is the SDK?
XIANGTIAN DAI: The Google+ iOS
SDK provides a library,
headers, and a sample app to
help you to integrate the
Google+ components with
your own app.
So the SDK will make it easy
for you to create a more
engaging experience and to
connect with more users by
integrating social into your
app using this Google+
platform features.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So inside the
SDK, we have the Quickstart,
which is the sample
application.
Xiangtian, here, is the author
of this sample application.
And what can you tell us
about the Quickstart
application for iOS?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes, the
Quickstart application is a
iOS Xcode project which lets
you get started with the
Google+ platform in less
than 10 minutes.
The app demonstrates using the
Google+ Sign-In button using
the SDK method to list people
that user has circled and also
making request to other
Google+ APIs.
The first requirement is to
install Xcode 4.5 or later.
The second requirement is, of
course, to download SDK, but
we'll get to this later.
First, we need to create our
API Console project.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And let me
show you how to do it.
The first thing, you need to
load the Google APIs Console,
which can be reached going--
you would see the Terms of
Services for the API.
And it's really important that
you read the Terms of Service
carefully because they will tell
you what your app can and
cannot do when using
the Google+ API.
So once this is done, let's
scroll up again.
And now it's the time to
configure the API Access for
your application.
So let's click on API Access.
What we need is an
02 Client ID.
And it's very easy
to create it.
We have this big blue button.
Let's just click it.
Now we need to input
the branding
information for our project.
And this information will be
shown to the users when they
see the consent dialogue.
So it's very important that the
information that you input
here is meaningful
for the user.
So use a product name that is
the name of your application.
If you have a product logo, use
a compelling product logo
here because it will be
shown in the consent
dialogue to the user.
And if you have a home page
URL for your application,
insert it here so that the user
can fetch more info about
your app at the time of giving
consent to your app for
accessing Google APIs
on their behalf.
We can now click Next.
And now we are actually
configuring the Client ID.
The first thing that we need
to do is choose the
application type.
And in our case it's an
installed application.
And it's an iOS installed
application.
After we chose iOS, we can see
some parameters, which are
specific to an iOS app.
Xiangtian, can you explain
to us these parameters?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Of course.
So there's basically
three fields.
The first field is the Bundle
ID, which we need to enter the
bundle identifier from your
application's project summary.
For our Quickstart sample
app, this is
com.google.GooglePlusSample.
But, of course, you will
need to enter your own
app's Bundle ID there.
Note that this Bundle ID will
also be used as a URL scheme
for browsers or other apps to
pass data back to your app,
which we'll discuss about
it a little bit later.
Now, if your app is published
in the Apple's iTunes App
Store, enter your App Store
ID in the App Store
ID field down there.
So you can determine the ID from
the ID part of your app
URL on the iTunes website.
For example, it's like,
itunes.apple.com/us/app/id
some number.
And that number we'll
put it there if you
have a published app.
Now, there's also a flag for
deep linking, which we'll talk
about it another time.
And note that you can always
come back and update the
settings for any of these
clients anytime later.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah, so now,
if I click Create Client ID,
this will create.
And, as Xiangtian said, again
click on Edit Setting if I
want to bring the configuration
back and update
some of the settings.
Another thing to notice that if
you have other apps-- for
example, if you have a web
application, and it's the same
as this application--
you can create another
Client ID.
And this will allow you to share
the branding info so
that you can have consistent
branding information that will
be shown to the users in the
consent dialogues across the
different platforms
that you support.
So now that this is done, the
next step to get things
started with the Quickstart are
downloading the app, open
the Xcode project, and replace
the Client ID in the source
code with the Client ID that
you've just created.
And Xiangtian, now, is
going to show it to
us, from his Xcode.
XIANGTIAN DAI: All right.
So let's see.
I have already downloaded
Google+ iOS SDK 1.2.1, which
is later version,
on my desktop.
I will open this app.
And it has a sample code
directory, which is a
Quickstart sample.
And inside there,
we should see--
let me do it again, sorry.
SILVANO LUCIANI: OK.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes, the
GooglePlusSample.Xcode project.
Let me open it in the Xcode.
As Silvano just said, we need to
replace the Client ID with
what we have registered
in the API Console.
For example, here, just copy
and paste the string value.
All right.
And then, click Run.
The sample is running, and let's
see how Sign-In works.
So first, I tap in Google+
Sign-In It will take me to a
web browser.
Note that if you have Google+
app installed, the user will
actually be directed to Google+
app, where user no
longer need to type in their
username and password, so to
give you that Google+ Single
Sign-on experience.
However, on this computer,
I don't
have Google+ app installed.
Now I'm directed to browser.
And I need to type in my
username and password.
After I tap Sign-In, I'm
shown a consent screen.
What can you tell about
this consent screen?
SILVANO LUCIANI: So this is the
consent screen where the
user can authenticate your
application to login and
access the Google+ API
on the user's behalf.
We saw the title is the name
that you used configured in
the API Console.
If we had a logo, we would
see the logo as well.
And now Xiangtian is showing to
you what the app is asking
to the user.
So the very first line is
knowing name [INAUDIBLE], and
also a list of people you are
connected to on Google+.
And that will be visible to
this application when they
used the people.list method.
Now, the user can
edit this list.
So they can choose to make all
their circle visible, or just
a selection of the circle.
The most important thing to
know is that the API will
never expose information about
your circle to the app.
The users will be returned
as a flat list.
In the second part, the consent
dialogue is showing
which type of app
activities this
application wants to write.
And, in this case, we have
the general app activity.
We have purchases, check-in
information,
comments, and so on.
At this point, the user can
choose to which users these
app activities will
be visible.
Once again, they can choose
all the circle.
They can choose a subset
of their circles.
But very importantly, as a
permanent option, they have
Only You, which means that the
activity will be private and
visible to the users only.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
OK, so let's say we accept.
And this will get back to
third-party app, so in our
case, Google+ Sample.
And my Sign-In has
been succeeded.
So that's for the Quickstart
sample app.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Now,
that was easy.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yeah.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Now, you
promised us something.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So what
did you promise us?
I want to see it.
XIANGTIAN DAI: I promised to
start a new app from scratch
that has a Google+ Sign-In
button just like in the
Quickstart sample app.
And let's see how it works.
First I install this,
just in case.
All right.
And then close Xcode window.
So I'm going to into the Xcode,
have this New, Project.
Now, I'm going to use a
single-view application just
for demonstration purpose.
And I'm going to call it
GooglePlusSample as well.
But this name doesn't
really matter.
You're going to use
your own name.
And use all default settings
and create on
the desktop as well.
All right?
So the first step is to
integrate the library and
headers and open source files
from Google+ SDK, which we
have downloaded into desktop.
To do that, you need to add
these files into our new app.
We add to that directory,
library and open source.
Now, what I do here, is to
create groups for any added
folders, but if you have already
been using some of
open source files in your own
app, you may want to add them
individually, so you don't end
up having duplicate open
source files in two different
directories.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Makes sense.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Click Add.
Still, we need to do some
tweaking of settings.
The first thing is that we need
to add two frameworks.
One is the security.
And the second, is system
configuration.
We also need to change View
settings to add a new link for
that, if you're not
already using it.
The identifier would be dash
object of C. This ensures
libraries with objects
of C, classes with
categories, links correctly.
So it's dash object C as part
of other link for apps.
And the third one, as we
mentioned earlier, we need to
add the Bundle ID as the
URL scheme we support.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So we
already seen this.
This is the one that we
configured before in the API
Console project.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
So in our case, it's
com.Google.GoolePlusSample.
All right.
So that's all the
first settings.
But we still, the same as what
we did for the Quickstart
sample app, we still need to
set the Client ID, which is
the Client ID for our
newly-created app Google API
Console client.
So here, we add an import,
GPPSignIn.
And here, in application did
finish with [INAUDIBLE],
launching with options,
we add GPPSignIn.
sharedInstance].clientID equals
to some value, which is
still in my clipboard, which
is the same thing here.
SILVANO LUCIANI: It's the same
Client ID that we created for
the project before.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
Now the application is ready.
But it does not do
anything yet.
Let's see how we add the
Sign-In button to this
application.
Let's open Storyboard.
Or if your app use XIB file,
that would work, too.
We add a control, a button.
Give it some size.
Remove the label because Sign-In
library will add their
own labels and give the class,
called it GPPSignInButton.
Of course, if you prefer not to
use a UI editor, by rather
do it programmatically, you
can do that as well.
All right.
Let's see how it works.
I will use iPhone simulator
and run.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Build
succeeded, but--
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yeah, the build
succeeds, but we have a small
problem here.
Let me try again.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Live demos.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yeah,
those live demos.
Reset the simulator.
SILVANO LUCIANI: OK.
So Xiangtian has reset the
status of the iOS simulator.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Let's
try it again.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Let's
try again the build.
No.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Since it didn't
work out, this--
SILVANO LUCIANI: The live
demo is not with us.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yeah.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Do you
have a working--
XIANGTIAN DAI: Let's see if I
have working version before.
SILVANO LUCIANI: This is the
sample that we build just
before starting, which
was working.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Which
was working, but
it didn't work either.
Bummer.
SILVANO LUCIANI: That's what
happen when you try
to do a live demo.
There is something wrong.
Anyway, I don't have a
clock, but that was
less than 10 minutes.
And we did 99% of it.
We leave you the 1% to you
at home as homework.
I'm pretty sure that
you will succeed.
Do we want to move to some
questions, Xiangtian?
We have some questions
that are occurring.
So the first one is, does
Google+ Sign-In work for user
that don't have the Google+
app installed
on their iOS device?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
I think I already mentioned it
during demo that if you have a
Google+ app installed, the
user will be directed to
Google+ app.
They don't have to
sign in again.
And will redirect back to
your app immediately.
However, if you do not have the
Google+ app, it will just
use a web browser, which you'll
need to sign in, if
you're not already signed in.
And then go to this consent
form, like we have demoed.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Second question
is, does it work for
users that do not have
a Google+ account?
I can reply to this.
If they don't have a Google+
account, we have a very fast
flow, which is composed of two
screens, which will allow them
to create or upgrade the
user to Google+.
And they will be able to access
it in 10 seconds, 15
seconds at most.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Yes.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So I think we
don't have any more questions.
Do you want to make another
try to fix it?
Or should we call it a day?
XIANGTIAN DAI: Let's
see if it works.
SILVANO LUCIANI: While Xiangtian
is trying to fix the
live demo, let me remind you
that you can find docs on
everything that we show you
and even more, all the
functionalities that the Google+
platform offers, at
the developers.google.com/plus.
If you want to see more code
examples, go to our
[INAUDIBLE]
on GitHub--
github.com/googleplus.
And you will find all
the Quickstarts.
And also you will find the
source code for PhotoHunt,
which is our end-to-end
sample application.
We have a Java backend.
We have an iOS client.
And we have an Android client.
If you have any additional
questions, you can reach us in
the Google+ Developer Community
on Google+.
And also you can use Stack
Overflow, use the tag
Google-Plus.
We monitor questions on the tag
daily, and we try to reply
as fast as we can, usually
within the same day.
Also, if you have any feature
requests, or if you want to
file a bug, user-issued trigger,
You can find the URL
for the issue trigger in
our developer docs.
And this will allow Xiangtian to
fix bugs in the iOS if you
find any bugs on the iOS.
Ask to fix bugs on
any of the other
features of the platform.
And if you have feature
requests, remember to star
your feature request so that
we'll be able to grade the
feature request and take it
into account first feature
request with a higher
priority.
[INAUDIBLE]
for today.
Well, I think you did great.
Live demoing is live demoing.
So Xiangtian, thanks
for coming.
Thanks for joining us.
XIANGTIAN DAI: Thank you for
letting me join this live
presentation.
And sorry for the demo.
SILVANO LUCIANI: No worries.
And see you soon.
XIANGTIAN DAI: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]